أهلاً بكم مجدداً في الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي. أنا Olivia Lanes وحلقة اليوم الثالثة ستركز على
تجربة QAOA على مستوى الفائدة العملية. إذا كنتم معنا منذ البداية فقد رأيتمونا نستعرض
عتاد IBM Quantum وإطار عمل أنماط Qiskit وأحدث وأفضل تقنيات تخفيف الأخطاء التي
يستخدمها الباحثون والمطورون لتوسيع نطاق الدوائر الكمومية. شعرنا أنه من المهم جداً أن نعطيكم كل هذا
السياق ونريكم الاتجاه الذي نسير فيه لكن الآن لا يوجد سبب للانتظار أكثر لرؤية كل هذه المعلومات في
التطبيق العملي. بعض الأشياء لتتذكروها قبل أن نبدأ: كل شيء سيتبع إطار عمل أنماط
Qiskit لذا سنمر بهذه الخطوات بالترتيب. رقم واحد تعيين المشكلة، اثنان تحسين الـ circuit، ثلاثة
التنفيذ باستخدام Primitives وأربعة المعالجة اللاحقة أو تحليل النتائج. سنبدأ بمثال صغير نسبياً
حتى تتمكنوا جميعاً من فهم هذه الخطوات وغرضها بشكل أفضل ثم سنناقش مثالاً مشابهاً جداً لكن أكبر
بكثير لنريكم كيف يمكن توسيع المشكلة إلى مستوى 100 qubit. سأعطيكم جميع
الأدوات للسماح لكم بالمضي قدماً بعد هذا الدرس وتشغيل تلك المشكلة بشكل مستقل. أخيراً هذا لن يكون
شرحاً للكود. مهما حاولنا مع تقدمنا يصبح الكود قديماً ومهملاً لذا إذا شاهدتم
هذا الفيديو بعد سنة من إطلاقه لا أريدكم أن تتوقفوا عند الصياغة التي قد تتغير قليلاً مع الوقت. بدلاً من ذلك سيكون هذا
نقاشاً مفصلاً للمنطق وصياغة المشكلة. لكن هناك دفتر تعليمي مرافق لهذا
الفيديو مرفق في الوصف أدناه. متابعة الكود أو الرجوع إليه بعد
مشاهدة هذا الدرس وتشغيله بأنفسكم سيعطيكم أفضل تجربة تعلم ممكنة. كتذكير سريع ليست
كل المشاكل الحسابية مناسبة للحوسبة الكمومية. المشاكل السهلة والحسابات البسيطة لا تحتاج للاستفادة
من هذه التقنية لأن الحواسيب الكلاسيكية جيدة تماماً في حلها بالفعل. اعتباراً من 2024
المجالات الثلاثة التي نحن أكثر تفاؤلاً بشأن استكشافها هي: محاكاة الطبيعة ومعالجة البيانات ذات البنية
المعقدة وأخيراً التحسين. مشاكل التحسين هي من أصعب المشاكل الحسابية
التي يمكن حلها بكفاءة. في مشكلة تحسين تبحثون عن أكبر أو أصغر قيمة ممكنة
لدالة تكلفة معطاة. لكن للعديد من المشاكل المهمة إيجاد هذا القيمة القصوى يصبح أصعب أسياً
مع حجم المشكلة. لهذا يصبح الحساب صعباً جداً. كمثال يمكنكم تخيل مدى
صعوبة حساب مسارات الطيران المثلى أو مسارات التوصيل عبر البلاد. في هذا الدرس سنستكشف
مشكلة تحسين معينة تُسمى Max Cut والتي سنحلها باستخدام خوارزمية
كمومية تُسمى خوارزمية التحسين التقريبي الكمومي أو QAOA. إذاً ما هي مشكلة Max Cut؟
مشكلة القطع الأقصى هي نوع من مشاكل التحسين التوافقي المعرفة على رسم بياني حيث الهدف هو
تقسيم رؤوس الرسم البياني إلى مجموعتين فرعيتين بحيث يكون عدد الحواف بين المجموعتين
أقصى ما يمكن. مثلاً في هذا الرسم البياني هنا كل عقدة متصلة هكذا والقطع الأقصى موضح بهذا الخط المتعرج
الذي يقسم العقد إلى المجموعة البنفسجية والمجموعة الرمادية. طريقة القيام بهذا بعبور أكبر
عدد ممكن من الحواف هي القطع عبر خمس حواف لهذا الرسم البياني هنا. لأن الرسم البياني صغير جداً
ليس صعباً تجربة بعض القطوع الممكنة على الورق أو حتى في رأسك ومعرفة أن خمسة هو أفضل خيار
ممكن. لكن تخيلوا لو تضاعف عدد العقد ثم تضاعف ثلاثاً. بسرعة يصبح هذا مستحيلاً يدوياً
وبعد عدد معين يصبح صعباً لدرجة أن حتى الحواسيب الفائقة تكافح لإرجاع أفضل إجابة بشكل موثوق. وذلك لأن
العدد الأقصى من القطوع يتوسع أسياً مع عدد العقد. رغم أن هذا قد يبدو مجرداً بعض الشيء
هناك العديد من المشاكل الواقعية التي يمكن صياغتها كمشكلة Max Cut مثل اكتشاف الاحتيال في المالية وتجميع
الرسوم البيانية وتصميم الشبكات وتصميم VLSI. وكذلك تحليل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
مثال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي سهل الفهم بشكل خاص. لنقل أنكم تريدون إيجاد مجموعة من الأفراد لديهم أكبر عدد ممكن
من الروابط مع أفراد آخرين على منصة تواصل اجتماعي لتحديد المستخدمين المؤثرين أو الأشخاص الذين لديهم
أكبر تأثير في مجموعة. الشركات تحاول فعل هذا بشكل متكرر. نقطة أخيرة هنا: القطع الأقصى غالباً
ما يكون روتيناً فرعياً لمشكلة أكبر لذا قد لا يُعرّف التطبيق الفعلي لكنه يُستخدم في الخلفية. إنه
أكثر شيوعاً مما قد تعتقدون. الآن حان وقت البدء.
الخطوة الأولى هي إنشاء الرسم البياني. يمكنكم فعل ذلك باستيراد حزمة Python تُسمى rustworks وتحديد عدد
العقد التي تعملون بها بتحديد الرقم n ثم إضافة عقدكم إلى الرسم البياني G. ستحتاجون أيضاً
لرسم حوافكم. سنفعل هذا يدوياً هنا بسرد الحواف في مصفوفة هكذا حيث تُظهرون الرقم
الأخير الذي يحدد وزن الحافة أو مدى قوة اتصال العقدتين المحددتين. هنا سنلتزم
بوزن واحد للجميع لكن قد تستمتعون بتجربة أوزان مختلفة لاحقاً ورؤية كيف يتغير الحل
لاكتساب فهم لما يعنيه الوزن في هذا السياق. لنعد إلى مثال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي. يمكنكم التفكير
في هذا الوزن كمدى تأثير شخص ما على آخر. اتصالكم بزوجكم أو قريبكم
مثلاً سيُعطى على الأرجح وزناً أعلى من شخص هو مجرد معرفة. الآن ارسموا الرسم البياني.
الدفتر التعليمي المرفق سيُريكم الصياغة الصحيحة. أولاً قبل النظر في كيفية
تعيين هذه المشكلة على circuit كمومية لنبنِ بعض السياق حول كيف تصبح مشكلة Max Cut مشكلة تحسين
في الأساس. نبدأ أولاً بالنظر في تصغير دالة f من x حيث المدخل x هو
متجه ذو n بُعداً مكوناته تتوافق مع كل عقدة في الرسم البياني. سنشير إلى هذه الدالة من الآن
فصاعداً بدالة التكلفة. ثم نحتاج لتقييد كل من هذه المكونات لتكون إما صفراً أو
واحداً هنا بمعنى على جانب واحد من القطع أو الآخر. يمكننا كتابة دالة
كزوج من العقد xi و xj التي تخبرنا ما إذا كانت الحافة المقابلة في القطع. بالتالي الكمية xi + xj
ناقص xi مضروبة في xj تحدد ما إذا كانت الحافة في القطع. إذا كانت هذه الكمية تساوي
واحداً فهذا يعني أن الحافة في القطع وإلا فهي صفر والحافة ليست فيه. مشكلة إيجاد
العدد الأقصى من الحواف في القطع يمكن صياغتها كتعظيم لهذه الدالة. بعد ذلك سنضيف فعلاً
إشارة سالبة شاملة لهذه الدالة مما يجعل المشكلة الجديدة مكافئة لإيجاد الحد الأدنى لهذه الدالة
بدلاً من ذلك، وبالتالي الحد الأدنى لـ f من x في هذه الحالة سيكون عندما يكون عدد الحواف التي يعبرها القطع هو
الأقصى. نختار صياغة هذه المشكلة كمشكلة تصغير لأن هذا يسمح لنا لاحقاً بتعيينها على مشكلة تصغير
طاقة أي إيجاد الحالة الأرضية وهو ما تجيده الحواسيب الكمومية بشكل طبيعي
لكن تذكروا لا يوجد شيء متعلق بالحوسبة الكمومية هنا بعد. لا نزال بحاجة لإعادة صياغة هذه المشكلة إلى
شيء يمكن للحاسوب الكمومي فهمه. نحن الآن مستعدون للتعمق والبدء بالعمل و
الخطوة الأولى هي تعيين المشكلة على circuit كمومية. قد لا يبدو واضحاً كيف
سننتقل من رسم بياني كالذي رسمناه إلى circuit كمومية لكن لنأخذ الأمر ببطء. تذكروا أننا
سنحاول حل مشكلة Max Cut هذه باستخدام QAOA. في خوارزمية QAOA نريد في النهاية أن يكون لدينا مشغل
وهو الهاملتوني الذي سيُستخدم لتمثيل دالة التكلفة لمشكلتنا بالإضافة إلى
circuit ذات معاملات وهي الأنساتز أو الحالة التجريبية التي سنستخدمها لتمثيل حالات كمومية هي تخمينات مدروسة أو مرشحة
لحل المشكلة. يمكننا أخذ عينات من هذه الحالات المرشحة ثم تقييمها
باستخدام دالة التكلفة. في هذه الحالة دالة التكلفة هي f من x لكننا نحتاج للتعبير عنها بطريقة
تبدو طبيعية للحاسوب الكمومي. لهذا سنستفيد من سلسلة من التحويلات الرياضية
للتعبير عن f من x كدالة طاقة وهي الهاملتوني. الخطوة الأولى من
العملية هي التعبير عن مشكلة تصغير f من x كمشكلة تحسين ثنائي تربيعي غير مقيد
أو QUBO اختصاراً. QUBO هي طريقة عامة لصياغة مشاكل التحسين التوافقي هذه
هنا Q هي مصفوفة N في N من الأعداد الحقيقية و N يتوافق مع عدد
العقد في رسمنا البياني، خمسة في مثالنا هذا، و X هو نفس متجه المتغيرات الثنائية من الصياغة
الأولية. لتشغيل خوارزمية QAOA بشكل فعال نحتاج للتعبير عن مشكلة التحسين بدلالة
هاملتوني وهو مشغل رياضي يمثل الطاقة الكلية لنظام. تحديداً نريد
إنشاء هاملتوني دالة التكلفة الذي لديه الخاصية بأن طاقة حالته الأرضية أو أدنى قيمة ذاتية
تتوافق مع الحد الأدنى للدالة التي تُشفر العدد الأقصى من القطوع على الرسم البياني G. بمجرد أن يكون لدينا
هذا الهاملتوني كل ما نحتاج فعله لحل مشكلة التحسين هو تحضير الحالة الأرضية للهاملتوني على الحاسوب الكمومي ثم
أخذ عينات من هذه الحالة سيعطي باحتمال عالٍ حل تصغير f من x. كما يتضح
نحن محظوظون لأن مشكلة QUBO مرتبطة ارتباطاً وثيقاً بل ومكافئة حسابياً
لأحد أشهر الهاملتونيات وأكثرها انتشاراً في الفيزياء وهو هاملتوني Ising. لكتابة مشكلة QUBO
كهاملتوني Ising كل ما نحتاج فعله هو تغيير متغيرات بسيط للانتقال من
المتغيرات البولية 0 و 1 إلى متغيرات اللف -1 و 1. هذه الخطوة
مباشرة وموضحة بالتفصيل في ملحق الدفتر المرفق لمن يهمه الأمر. لكن في النهاية تصغير تعبير QUBO
هذا هو نفسه تصغير هذا التعبير. بإعادة الكتابة قليلاً مرة أخرى
يصبح لدينا هاملتوني دالة التكلفة حيث الحد الأدنى للتعبير يمثل الحالة الأرضية و Z
يصبح مشغل Pauli Z بينما B هو معامل عددي حقيقي. الآن بعد أن أصبح لدينا
الهاملتوني من السهل إعادة كتابته بدلالة مشغلات Pauli ZZ المحلية الثنائية التي ستتحول بسهولة إلى
بوابات ثنائية الـ qubit في الـ circuit الكمومية. يرجى الرجوع إلى الدفتر المرفق لرؤية كيف يتم ذلك لكن المخرج
موضح في هذا السطر هنا. لاحظوا أنه في مثالنا هناك
ستة كائنات أو سلاسل Pauli لأن كلاً منها يمثل حافة في الرسم البياني. طول السلسلة يطابق عدد
العقد لذا IIZZZ هي خمس عقد والسلسلة ستتكون من
وحدات في جميع المواقع ما عدا مؤشرات العقد المشاركة في حافة والتي ستحتوي على حدود Z. في Qiskit
سلاسل البت التي تمثل الـ qubit مفهرسة بالعكس. مثلاً الحافة بين العقدتين 0 و 1 ستُشفر كـ
IIIZZ. مع كتابة الهاملتوني بدلالة Pauli نحن مستعدون لبناء
الـ circuit الكمومية. هذه الـ circuit الكمومية ستساعدنا في أخذ عينات لحلول جيدة من الحاسوب الكمومي. خوارزمية QAOA
مستوحاة من النظرية الكظومية التي تنص على أنه إذا بدأنا في الحالة الأرضية لهاملتوني يعتمد على الزمن
وإذا تطور الهاملتوني ببطء كافٍ ومُنح وقتاً كافياً فإن الحالة النهائية ستكون الحالة الأرضية
للهاملتوني النهائي. يمكن اعتبار QAOA كنسخة Trotter المنفصلة من الخوارزمية الكمومية
الكظومية حيث كل خطوة Trotter تمثل طبقة نسميها P لذا
بدلاً من التطور من حالة إلى أخرى في كل طبقة من P سنتبادل بين هاملتوني
دالة التكلفة وشيء يُسمى هاملتوني الخلط الذي سنسمع عنه أكثر بعد قليل. لكن النقطة التي أريد توضيحها
هي أن QAOA لديها ميزة كونها أسرع من الخوارزمية الكمومية الكظومية لكنها تُرجع حلولاً تقريبية
بدلاً من المثلى. في الحد حيث عدد الطبقات يذهب إلى اللانهاية تتقارب QAOA مع الحالة
الكظومية لكن بالطبع هذا مكلف حسابياً جداً. لإنشاء الـ circuit الكمومية
سنطبق مشغلات متناوبة هنا ذات معاملات gamma و beta التي
ستمثل التقسيم المنفصل لتطور الزمن. مرة أخرى الأجزاء الثلاثة الرئيسية
من circuit الـ QAOA هي: أولاً الحالة التجريبية الأولية بالرمادي وهي الحالة الأرضية
لهاملتوني الخلط من التطور الكظومي المُنشأة بتطبيق بوابة Hadamard على كل qubit. ثانياً
تطور دالة التكلفة الذي لدينا بالفعل بالبنفسجي الداكن. وثالثاً التطور تحت هاملتوني
الخلط الذي لم نناقشه بعد بالبنفسجي الفاتح. هاملتوني البداية يُسمى
الخلاط لأن حالته الأرضية هي التراكب لجميع سلاسل البت الممكنة المهمة وبالتالي
يفرض خليطاً من جميع الحلول الممكنة في البداية. هاملتوني الخلط هو مجموع بسيط لعمليات Pauli X
على كل عقدة في الرسم البياني. Qiskit يسمح لكم باستخدام مشغل خلط مخصص مختلف إذا أردتم لكن
في هذه الحالة سنستخدم المعياري. مرة أخرى يمكنكم رؤية أنه مع Qiskit الكثير من العمل
يُزال عنا مما يجعل إيجاد هاملتوني الخلط والحالة الابتدائية أمراً بسيطاً. العمل الوحيد الذي كان علينا القيام به هو
إيجاد دالة التكلفة. كل تكرار لهذه المشغلات يُسمى طبقة. يمكن رؤية هذه الطبقات
كتقسيمات منفصلة لتطور النظام الزمني كما وصفنا سابقاً. النمط المتناوب يأتي من
تفكيك Trotter ويُقرّب الدوال الأسية للمصفوفات غير المتبادلة. بشكل عام كلما زادت الطبقات أو
الخطوات التي نضمنها كلما اقتربنا من التطور الزمني المستمر وبالتالي نظرياً ستكون النتيجة أدق
لكن في هذا المثال سنبدأ بأخذ عينات بطبقتين فقط. تذكروا أن كلاً من هاملتوني دالة التكلفة و
الخلاط لهما معاملات. لا نزال بحاجة لإيجاد القيم المثلى لـ gamma و
beta. أدرك أن تلك كانت معلومات كثيرة وإذا كانت هذه أول مرة ترون فيها هذا النوع من الرياضيات قد يكون صعباً. لحسن الحظ أحد الأشياء الرائعة
في Qiskit هو أن الكثير مما استعرضناه يمكن القيام به تلقائياً دون جهد كبير من المستخدم. من الجيد فهم ما يجري
في الخلفية خاصة عند التوسع لتجارب أكبر لكنكم لن تضطروا للقيام بكل هذا العمل
يدوياً في كل مرة. لقد عيّنا الآن مشكلتنا على circuit كمومية. كان الأمر يتطلب بعض العمل
لكن لا تقلقوا يصبح أسهل وأكثر بديهية كلما مارستموه أكثر. الآن نحن مستعدون للانتقال إلى الخطوة الثانية
تحسين الـ circuit للعتاد. بينما الـ circuit التي أنشأناها تبدو بسيطة جداً وهي
مفيدة لبناء فهم بديهي تذكروا أن الشريحة الكمومية لا تفهم ما هذا الكتلة المجردة
نحتاج لتحويلها إلى سلسلة من بوابات أحادية وثنائية الـ qubit أصلية للعتاد. وعندما أقول
أصلية أعني أنها ستُعاد صياغتها إلى ما يمكن تنفيذه مباشرة على الـ qubit. مثل هذه الدوائر
يُقال إنها مكتوبة بمعمارية مجموعة التعليمات الخاصة بالـ backend والتي قد ترونها مختصرة كدوائر ISA
وحدة transpiler في SDK الخاصة بـ Qiskit تقدم سلسلة من تمريرات النقل التي يمكنها
إجراء نطاق واسع من تحويلات الـ circuit. نريد التأكد من أن الـ circuit محسنة
لغرضنا. تذكروا من درسنا السابق أن عملية النقل والتحويل تتضمن عدة خطوات: تعيين
الـ qubit في الـ circuit أو متغيرات القرار على qubit فيزيائية على الجهاز وفك لف التعليمات في
الـ circuit الكمومية إلى التعليمات الأصلية للعتاد التي يفهمها الـ backend فعلاً وتوجيه أي
qubit في الـ circuit تتفاعل مباشرة إلى qubit فيزيائية متجاورة مع بعضها
البعض. وكالعادة مزيد من التفاصيل يمكن إيجادها على موقع التوثيق
الآن تأتي خطوة مثيرة حيث سنختار أي backend نشغل عليه الـ circuit. علينا فعل هذا
قبل خطوة النقل لأن الـ transpiler يُحسّن بشكل مختلف لمعالجات مختلفة. وهذا سبب آخر لأهمية
قدرة Qiskit على أتمتة الكثير من هذه المرحلة. لن تريدوا تحسين الـ circuit يدوياً
وهو ما يمكن فعله لكن أحياناً يكون صعباً ويستهلك وقتاً كثيراً فقط لتدركوا أنكم تريدون تشغيل
الـ circuit على معالج مختلف بخصائص مختلفة وعندها عليكم إعادة كل ذلك العمل. مرروا
الـ backend الذي اخترتموه عبر دالة الـ transpiler ولا تنسوا تحديد مستوى التحسين. هذه
المرة اخترت مستوى التحسين الثالث وهو الأعلى والأكثر شمولاً
وهذا كل شيء فعلياً للخطوة الثانية. الـ circuit تم نقلها تلقائياً ورسمتها هنا حتى
تتمكنوا من رؤية كيف تُرجمت إلى بوابات أحادية وثنائية الـ qubit. الآن حان وقت الخطوة الثالثة
تشغيل الـ circuit باستخدام Primitives في Qiskit. حتى الآن نقلنا الـ circuit تاركين المعاملات gamma و
beta كما هي لكن لا يمكننا تشغيل الـ circuit فعلياً دون تحديد قيم هذه المعاملات. في سير عمل
QAOA يتم إيجاد معاملات QAOA المثلى في حلقة تحسين تكرارية حيث نشغل سلسلة من تقييمات
الـ circuit ونستخدم محسناً كلاسيكياً لإيجاد معاملات beta و gamma المثلى. لكن نحتاج للبدء
من مكان ما لذا وضعت بعض التخمينات الأولية لـ gamma 1 و gamma 2 و beta 1 و beta 2 وهي Pi/2 و Pi
على التوالي. أريدكم أيضاً أن تلاحظوا أننا سنستخدم محسناً لإيجاد حلول أفضل لـ gamma و beta
وبما أنني أحسب طبقتين فقط حالياً فهذا كل ما أحتاجه. لكن إذا أنشأتم circuit QAOA أدق
ستضمنون طبقات أكثر وبالتالي تحتاجون gamma و beta محسنة لكل طبقة
متتالية. الآن لنتوقف لحظة هنا ونتذكر خياراتنا للـ Primitives. لدينا المقدر و
أخذ العينات. أيهما تعتقدون أننا سنستخدم لهذا النوع من المهام؟ حسناً مهما كان تخمينكم
فأنتم محقون فعلاً. سنستخدم كلاً من المقدر وأخذ العينات. لحلقة التحسين الأولية
سنحتاج المقدر لكننا سنستخدم أخذ العينات لاحقاً لقراءة الحل
النهائي. الآن نحن شبه مستعدين لتشغيل الخوارزمية أعدكم. لكن بسرعة من المهم ملاحظة أنه يمكنكم
إرسال مهمتكم بطرق متنوعة مختلفة تُسمى أوضاع التنفيذ. أولاً لدينا وضع المهمة وهو طلب
Primitive واحد للمقدر أو أخذ العينات بدون مدير سياق. الدوائر والمدخلات تُعبأ ككتل موحدة
للـ Primitive وتُقدم كمهمة تنفيذ على الحاسوب
الكمومي. وضع الدفعة هو مدير متعدد المهام لتشغيل تجربة بكفاءة تتكون من مجموعة
من المهام المستقلة. استخدموا وضع الدفعة لتقديم مهام Primitive متعددة في وقت واحد. وضع الجلسة هو نافذة
مخصصة لتشغيل عبء عمل متعدد المهام. هذا يسمح للمستخدمين المميزين بتجربة الخوارزميات التباينية بطريقة أكثر
قابلية للتنبؤ وحتى تشغيل تجارب متعددة في وقت واحد مستفيدين من التوازي في
المكدس. استخدموا الجلسات لسير العمل التكراري والتجارب التي تتطلب وصولاً مخصصاً. لتجربة QAOA
ستكون الجلسة خياراً جيداً للمتابعة إذا كان لديكم وصول إليها بما أنكم ستحتاجون لتجربة دوائر متعددة لقيم مختلفة من beta
و gamma. حسناً الآن لنعد إلى مشكلة التحسين. لقد عرّفنا بالفعل
هاملتوني دالة التكلفة HC وسير العمل الكامل هو هذا: خوارزمية QAOA
تبدأ بتهيئة الـ qubit في حالة التراكب ثم تطبق الأنساتز بطبقات P و
تهيئ معاملات gamma و beta ثم تشغل الـ circuit باستخدام Primitive المقدر. بمجرد حساب
القيم المتوقعة سنستخدم محسن SciPy يُسمى COBYLA. COBYLA
يُحسّن دالة التكلفة كلاسيكياً خارج وحدة المعالجة الكمومية. بمجرد تحديث قيم gamma و beta
نكرر العملية. سنفعل هذا حتى تتقارب قيمة دالة التكلفة الإجمالية وتصل إلى أدنى قيمة
ثم سنختار قيم gamma و beta التي تتوافق مع قيمة التكلفة المنخفضة هذه ونشغل الـ circuit مرة أخيرة
واحدة هذه المرة باستخدام أخذ العينات. هذه نتيجة تشغيلي لمحسن COBYLA مع تخميناتي الأولية. هنا يمكنكم رؤية
أن قيمة دالة التكلفة عبر التكرارات المنفذة تبدأ متذبذبة قليلاً وترتفع وتنخفض لكن
ثم تستقر عند قيمة منخفضة. سنستخدم آخر قيم gamma و beta التي تتوافق مع أدنى تقييم لدالة
التكلفة لتشغيل الـ circuit مرة أخيرة وأخذ عينة من سلسلة البت التي ستعطينا القطع
الأقصى. الآن باستخدام قيمنا المحسنة لـ gamma و beta سنشغل الـ circuit مرة أخيرة لإيجاد أفضل
سلسلة بت ممكنة باستخدام أخذ العينات. سردت القيم المحددة التي أستخدمها هنا لكن تذكروا عندما تجربون
بأنفسكم أو حتى تعيدون تشغيل نفس دفتر التعليم قد تتغير هذه القيم قليلاً. الآن سنشغل
الـ circuit المحسنة بهذه القيم ونجد حلنا المرشح لمشكلة Max Cut. إذا كنتم تستخدمون
الجلسات فلم يعد ذلك ضرورياً بما أننا نشغل مهمة أخيرة واحدة فقط. الآن سننظر أخيراً في
مرحلة المعالجة اللاحقة وإيجاد حلنا النهائي. أولاً لنرسم جميع
التوليفات الممكنة للعقد التي حولناها إلى سلاسل بت كمدرج تكراري. يمكنكم رؤية فوراً أنه
عندما شغلته وجدت أربعة حلول وميزتها بالبنفسجي وهي أكثر احتمالاً من أي حل آخر.
أعلى سلسلة بت وبالتالي الأكثر احتمالاً هي 01101. يرجى ملاحظة أن ترتيب الـ qubit
معكوس في الرسم. بالنظر في الحل الأكثر احتمالاً نلاحظ أن العقدتين 0 و 3 مجمعتان معاً
وبالمثل العقد 1 و 2 و 4. يمكننا أخيراً رسم سلسلة البت الأكثر
احتمالاً كرسم بياني وتذكروا أن سلسلة البت تتوافق ببساطة مع أرقام العقد وما إذا كانت مضمنة
بعلامة واحد أو غير مضمنة بعلامة صفر في تجميعنا. عندما نرسم القطع الآن يمكننا رؤية بأعيننا
الخط التقريبي لأفضل قطع الذي يمثل ببساطة التجميع المثالي لجميع العقد الخمس والذي رسمته هنا. شيء
واحد أريد أن أقضي بعض الوقت في مناقشته هنا هو حقيقة أن الحل الصحيح ليس فريداً
بسبب تناظر هذا الرسم البياني هناك حلول صحيحة متعددة. بدلاً من أن تكون العقدتان 0 و 3 داخل
القطع يمكن أن تكون العقدتان 2 و 4 مضمنتين ويمكنكم رؤية أن كل ما فعلته هو تدوير القطع
لتضمين هذه النقاط الجديدة. الحل وهو خمسة يبقى نفسه
لنلقِ نظرة أخرى على المدرج التكراري والحلول الأربعة الأكثر احتمالاً لدقيقة. آخر حلين هما
اللذان رسمناهما وهما صحيحان بنفس القدر. لكن هذا ليس كل شيء. يمكننا أيضاً عكس التلوين لجميع
الحلول الصحيحة وهذه المرة نفكر في العقد على أنها داخل مقابل خارج القطع. في
الشريحة السابقة حددنا حلين فريدين صحيحين لكن هناك فعلاً حلان آخران أحدهما يتوافق مع
عكس كل منهما. انظروا كيف هنا حيث رسمت الحلين المتبقيين كل ما فعلته هو عكس
الألوان. الآن المشكلة الوحيدة هي أن الخوارزمية لم تجد أو تحدد هذا الحل الرابع الأخير
كأحد أكثر أربع إجابات احتمالاً. كان الخامس. الحل الرابع الذي حددته الخوارزمية
هو في الواقع غير صحيح ولو رسمتموه سترون أن ذلك الحل يحتوي على أربع قطوع فقط وبما أن الآخرين
لديهم خمسة وأربعة أقل من خمسة بوضوح فهذا خاطئ. النقطة هنا
هي أن هذه خوارزمية تقريبية. ليست معصومة وليست صحيحة 100% من الوقت. عليكم
استخدام بعض معرفتكم وفهمكم للتحقق من سلامة الحلول. من الجدير بالإشارة أن
هذا الخطأ يمكن أن ينشأ من عدة أماكن. قد يكون من الطبيعة التقريبية للخوارزمية نفسها والعدد
الصغير من الطبقات التي اخترت استخدامها. قد يكون خطأ أخذ عينات محدود ويمكن تقليله بزيادة
عدد اللقطات في تجربتي. أو قد يكون خطأ قراءة بما أن الحل الحقيقي الرابع يختلف ببت واحد فقط
السبب في إشارتي لكل هذه الاحتمالات هو لأن هذا ما يتطلبه الأمر لتصبحوا ممارسين
كاملين للحوسبة الكمومية. تحتاجون لفهم أداء العتاد وكيف يمكن أن يسهم في
أنواع معينة من الأخطاء وكيفية تصحيحها. لكن لا ننسى أنه كان هناك
32 حل سلسلة بت ممكن وأن الحلول الأربعة الحقيقية كانت ضمن أفضل خمسة
مرشحين واستخدمت طبقتين فقط لإيجاد هذا. بشكل عام إذا أردت زيادة فرص إيجاد أفضل
قطع أقصى في كل مرة فسأزيد عمق الطبقات. هناك بعض التفاصيل الدقيقة في هذا لكنها لحلقة
لاحقة. الآن سأترككم تجربون بأنفسكم لكن هذه المرة ستستخدمون 100
qubit. إذا بدأنا برسم الرسم البياني ذي 100 qubit يمكنكم رؤية أنه لم يعد واضحاً أو حتى ممكناً
تخمين أين سيحدث القطع الأقصى. هناك ببساطة احتمالات كثيرة جداً لاختياره يدوياً لكن
حل هذه المشكلة باستخدام QAOA لا يزال ممكناً تماماً ويمكنكم اتباع نفس سير العمل الذي استخدمناه لـ 5
qubit. أنا على وشك إرسالكم بمفردكم وتكليفكم بمحاولة إجراء هذه التجربة لكن قبل ذلك
لنلخص. تذكروا أن الخطوات الست لأي مهمة QAOA هي كالتالي: أولاً تعريف
هاملتوني التكلفة بحيث تُشفر حالته الأرضية حل مشكلة التحسين. ثانياً تعريف
هاملتوني الخلط. ثالثاً بناء المشغلات المقابلة للهاملتونيات
المُرفعة أسياً. رابعاً بناء الـ circuit وستتكون من الحالة الأرضية الأولية للخلاط وطبقات
متناوبة متكررة لدالة التكلفة والتطور تحت هاملتونيات الخلط. خامساً تحضير حالة أولية و
استخدام تقنيات الحوسبة الكلاسيكية لتحسين المعاملات. سادساً تشغيل الـ circuit وقياس سلاسل البت المخرجة
بحثاً عن الحل الأكثر احتمالاً. الآن بعض الملاحظات هنا
استخدمت مستوى التحسين الثالث لمثالي ذي 5 qubit لكن ربما لم يكن ذلك ضرورياً والإجابة الصحيحة يمكن
أن تُرجع في معظم الأحيان بمستوى تحسين أقل لأن عمق الـ circuit كان منخفضاً نسبياً لحالة
5 qubit. لكن لـ 100 qubit وعمق circuit كبير ستحتاجون بشكل شبه مؤكد أعلى مستوى
تحسين لإيجاد الإجابة الصحيحة. كذلك تذكروا أن أحد أصعب أجزاء سير عمل مقياس الفائدة العملية
النموذجي هو مرحلة التعيين وإيجاد رسم بياني يتوافق جيداً مع طوبولوجيا IBM السداسية الثقيلة. لو كنتم
تقومون بهذا العمل من الصفر فهناك بلا شك حيث ستكرسون الكثير من وقتكم. حالياً هذا الجزء تم
إنجازه لكم لأن ذلك ليس الهدف الرئيسي من هذا التمرين. لكن تذكروا أنه شيء سيتطلب
ممارسة وتشغيل مهمة واسعة النطاق ليس دائماً بالأمر المباشر. سنتعمق أكثر في هذا
في الحلقة الرابعة. الـ circuit النهائية ستبدو بوضوح أكثر تعقيداً بكثير من الـ circuit التي شُغلت على 5 qubit
لكن من ناحية أخرى أشعر أن النظر إلى هذه الـ circuit ورؤية كم عدد البوابات فيها ومعرفة أن لديكم
القدرة على تشغيل هذا فعلاً على معالجات كمومية حقيقية أمر
مبهر جداً. وهذا كان حلي النهائي. يمكنكم رؤية أن الخوارزمية بالتأكيد قادرة على تجميع هذه
العقد في مجموعتين وتحديد أفضل قطع أقصى يقسمهما. الانتقال من المجموعتين
إلى خط القطع الأقصى نفسه أمر بسيط. في أي مكان يتغير اللون على الخطوط التي تربط العقد يحدد
أين يجب رسم خط القطع الأقصى. عندما شغلته قيمة القطع الأقصى التي تمكنت من تحقيقها هي
84. لذا جربوا بأنفسكم وأخبروني إذا حصلتم على شيء مشابه في التعليقات. جربوا ثلاث طبقات وربما أربع وجربوا
تغيير الأوزان بين العقد وشاهدوا كيف يتغير الناتج. هناك الكثير من التجارب المثيرة
التي يمكننا تشغيلها مع QAOA. تذكروا أنه ليس مضموناً أنني وجدت للتو أفضل حل
ممكن. نعلم أنه حل جيد لكن للمتعة أتحداكم لمحاولة التغلب علي. شاهدوا إن كنتم تستطيعون الحصول على شيء
أفضل من 84. في الختام QAOA خوارزمية ديناميكية جداً
وهناك الكثير من الحلول الاستدلالية والكثير لاستكشافه بعد. تعطي مجالاً كبيراً لتعلم أشياء جديدة
عن مجال التحسين بشكل عام. كان هناك الكثير من العمل مؤخراً في مجال التحسين كما
يتضح من جميع أوراق الأرشيف التي نُشرت مؤخراً عبر الإنترنت حول QAOA أو التحسين. وما هو
رائع حقاً هو أن أخيراً ليست كل هذه الأوراق أوراقاً نظرية. المنظرون عملوا على دراسة
QAOA لسنوات لكن الآن التجريبيون ينضمون لأن لدينا أخيراً العتاد
مثل معالجات IBM القادرة على تشغيل الكثير من هذه التجارب. ننتقل من الفضاء التخيلي
إلى العالم الحقيقي وهذا مثير جداً. نعم لا يزال هناك الكثير من العمل للقيام به ولا تزال هناك
الكثير من الأخطاء التي نحتاج لمعرفة كيفية التعامل معها لكننا نحرز تقدماً سريعاً وأنتم بمشاهدتكم هذا
الفيديو إذا وصلتم إلى هنا فأنتم قادرون على تشغيل هذه التجارب بأنفسكم. من فضلكم جربوا تشغيل تجربتكم
الخاصة ذات 100 qubit وأخبرونا كيف سارت الأمور. تابعوا مع الدفتر التعليمي وستكونون بأيدٍ أمينة وإذا
كانت لديكم أي أسئلة أو واجهتم صعوبات لا تقلقوا كلنا شعرنا بذلك أو كانت لدينا نفس الأسئلة عندما بدأنا
تعلم هذا لأول مرة. ابذلوا قصارى جهدكم وأخبرونا بالأسئلة التي تصادفكم وسنراكم في المرة القادمة
[موسيقى]